NABIL NAGHDY: Hi, everyone.
My name is Nabil Naghdy.
I'm the product manager on
the Google Maps API.
JOSH LIVNI: And my name
is Josh Livni.
I'm on the Maps Developer
Relations Team.
NABIL NAGHDY: So today, what we
wanted to talk to you about
was what you can do that's
more than just a map.
So today, there are over 800,000
sites that utilize the
Google Maps API.
And each one of them tries to
tell a special story, tries to
give the user a context
of where they are or
what they're doing.
Unfortunately, the majority of
these maps have got the iconic
red pin and stick it on a
map and say, I'm done.
Let's pack it up.
That's it, finished.
Whereas, there's so much more
you can add to a map to give
it extra context, to give it
more meaning and make a much
richer experience
for the users.
So what we're going to talk
about today, in this session,
is what are some of these
features, and how can they
relate to your site.
So what we'll do is we'll
start in 2005.
For those that came to the
session earlier, it's a little
bit of a history repeating
itself.
But what we have is, pre-2005,
the way you navigated a map
was you saw a static image
that was there for you.
And you pressed the
Right Arrow.
And the page would refresh, and
you'd get another image
that was slightly
to the right.
And that was pretty much it.
In 2005, Google launched
Google Maps.
For those that remember,
you take your mouse.
You put it on the map.
And you kind of double click.
It zooms in.
You're like, oh, that's
pretty cool.
I'm zooming in.
And then you move
the map around.
And you're like, wow,
the map is dynamic?
And it kind of changed the way
in which we interact with the
website, with a map,
specifically.
So this was the first time
that AJAX was actually
properly used on
a grand scale.
So the way that Google did this
was by pre-rendering all
the map tiles and then loading
them behind the scenes, so
that when you moved the map
around, it would just pull
that image and put it there.
So this was pretty revolutionary
in 2005.
A lot of people who saw
this thought, wow,
this is pretty cool.
What can I do to build
on top of this?
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
So a bunch of folks thought it
was amazing and immediately
started reverse-engineering
the JavaScript, trying to
figure out what was this
cross-domain stuff, how do we
sort of take control
of this map, put
our own data on there.
It was very exciting
to people.
The first mash-up was
the housingmaps.com.
It's still around, a pretty
venerable site.
It still looks a bit like it did
when it first launched, a
few changes, since it's
using the Maps API V2.
But it's important to remember
this was originally built
before there was an API.
It kind of instigated web APIs
as we know them today, mashups
as we know them today.
And really a lot of maps today
have a very similar story as
what we have right here, which
is, you have some data.
Maybe it's 10 points.
Maybe it's 10,000.
Maybe it's a couple million.
You're trying to display a
subset of them on a map so
people can interact with them.
And you end up with this kind
of a thing here, which is--
in this case, it's some
Craigslist data.
NABIL NAGHDY: So basically,
you've got a whole bunch of
cities where Craigslist
has property.
You have things like filters
for pricing and any other
information, really easy to
use, easy to navigate.
When you click on a pin, a
little pop up comes up with
pictures or any information
relevant to
that specific property.
So that was really awesome and
innovative, for its time.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
And again, this is a common
story that a lot of people
want to be able to--
I should click out of this
IFrame here-- a lot of people
want to be able to repeat.
And so, in order to think about
how would you rebuild
this type of thing today, let's
take a look what's,
first of all, changed in
the infrastructure.
If that's what you could do
seven years ago, when we had
basically one set of data, we'd
pre-render some tiles,
let's see what's a little
bit different today.
This is a very, very
simplified diagram.
You can imagine we have
more complex ones.
But the general story here is--
first of all, we have a
lot more data.
If you're looking up at the big
kind of gray box, we have
the imagery.
That was added a year
after, in 2006.
Then we have a bunch
of satellite data.
And we have a ton of imagery.
We have, in this kind of little
bucket here, over 20
petabytes of imagery
from various
different data sources.
That's a lot.
We have some other data we
throw on top of there.
Maybe it's like a
cycling layer.
Maybe it's live traffic coming
in from a bunch of different
data sources.
We have a lot more
places today.
We have over 80 million
places.
Again, kind of give you some
extra context of what's going
on around you, with
establishments and other types
of things, like landmarks
and so forth.
And then we have kind
of the main feature,
which is the roadmap.
And a ton of stuff has
changed there.
We're not going to go in too
much detail here, except to
say, the major things that have
changed is, one, there's
this kind of feedback loop
that's just much faster.
First of all, you can
report problems.
We'll take a look.
You can edit the map directly
at Map Maker.
Once that edit has been
moderated, sometimes they're
automatically approved.
Simple edit, and we trust you,
for various reasons, like
you've made previously
good edits.
And then those go live.
And a matter of minutes later,
it'll be globally distributed.
And then, finally, we custom
push out the tiles to you now.
So if you remember back seven
years ago, we kind of scoffed
at that idea that you click
Right and then it renders a
Map View, and 10 seconds
later you have one.
Now, you make a change to the
style of your map or add some
layer, and you hit a little
button in JavaScript, and 10
milliseconds later, you have
a bunch of tiles that are
custom-generated just for
you, [? appropriate ?]
language and so forth.
NABIL NAGHDY: It's
really powerful.
It's a really strong way to
display all this imagery.
And it's incredibly fast.
So looking at what the current
architecture is, how would we
go about creating--
in this example, for today,
we'll look at
a real estate site.
And so what would be
the simplest way
for you to do that?
And what are the different ways
in which we can use the
different features of the Maps
API Suite to enhance the real
estate platform, on top of what
we've seen, from what
HousingMaps did?
JOSH LIVNI: So again, this is
a really common problem,
applies to a ton of different
verticals.
Maybe you're looking for
ski resorts in Tahoe.
You could be looking for local
soccer fields or burrito
places in San Francisco.
Or you have a chain of hotels,
or what have you.
We're going to do the kind of
HousingMaps example here, with
the real estate sites.
But this Store Locator, as you
could imagine, applies well to
someone with a bunch
of stores.
And it solves the same
kind of problem.
I have a bunch of points.
I want to allow people to be
able to find what's around me,
as I say, the closest store.
And this library is a third
party library, put together by
my colleague Chris Broadfoot.
It's available at
storelocator.googlecode.com.
So it's just an open
source library.
I'm just mentioning it here as
a really great way to kind of
bootstrap the site.
So you don't have to write all
of this code from scratch.
If you have this general
problem, you've got a bunch of
points, you want people to be
able to say, here's where I
am, What's around me, and a
bunch of extra stuff we're
going to do in a minute, it's a
really great library to get
started with.
So we're going to show you
a few features of that.
I first just want to point out
that it's got great reference
documentation.
It just works really nicely,
a bunch of great features.
We're going to talk about a few
of them right now, with
our House Locator.
NABIL NAGHDY: So when you import
your data, which we'll
talk about in a second, you
get an awesome experience,
right off the bat.
So as you can see,
we've got all the
markers that we've imported.
We've got about two and a half
thousand different houses we
got from the King County
government, from their
property sales data.
So what is already built into
the store locator is the
ability to search for
a specific location.
So let's say Google
in Kirkland.
We have a Kirkland office.
So as you can see, there
was autocomplete there.
And what it's done is, it's
re-framed our map to center on
Google Kirkland and then
reordered all the properties
or all the pins to basically
sort by distance, away from
the location.
So let's change it to Google
Fremont, which is our other
office in Seattle.
And we can see that all the pins
have been reordered, as
you can see on the map.
So it's really powerful.
The other thing that's also
available that comes for free
in the Store Locator, built
in, is a global filter.
So you can set any variable
to be filtered.
In this instance, because
Seattle is unbearably cold,
we've decided to include
a fireplace.
So if you click on fireplace,
it filters out all the
properties that don't have a
fireplace with the ones that
do, and displays them
on the map.
In the same way, if you're a ski
resort site, you can say,
which ski fields have got
specialized for snowboarding.
Or there's so many
ways in which you
can use these variables.
And it's all pretty much
part and parcel
of the Store Locator.
JOSH LIVNI: All right.
So I'm just going to walk you
through, just very briefly.
This session is not about
the Store Locator.
But we're kind of going to use
it as a basis for building up
the rest of these
examples here.
So just to explain the minimal
amount of concepts you need to
have to build up the
Store Locator.
And in maybe less than 100
lines of code, we've put
together that map that
you saw right there.
So first of all, after
downloading the Store Locator
library, we start up with
creating a data feed.
And the data feed here, we're
using a static data feed,
because I put the houses in kind
of a big JSON file, so I
could stream them over easily,
and parse them, and so forth.
It could be a CSV
file you parse.
Maybe it's like a
collaboratively edited
spreadsheet.
It could also be a dynamic
data feed.
So it has good examples
for that, as well.
So if you have, say a MySQL
database with millions of
points, then you'd just grab a
bounding box query to show the
closest ones for the map.
Or it could be an App Engine
server or Fusion Tables.
They launched a new API that
let's you do JSONP callbacks.
That worked really well.
The point being, it's data
source agnostic.
So whatever data you have,
it's pretty easy
to bring it in here.
You don't have to worry about
this sort of geo store and the
magic of auto-sorting
and so forth.
The closest one is taken care
for you in the JavaScript.
Then you create a View.
And you basically feed that
a map that you've already
instantiated, and
the data feed.
There's some options on the
View, for example, the one I
have here, the geolocation.
By default, it's true.
And then, when the Store Locator
loads, it'll say, do
you allow the map to
have your location?
It'll center on your location,
which is nice.
But we set it to false.
So I can use the autocomplete,
which also comes for free.
And then you create, if you
want, the left panel.
So you kind of get that panelDiv
that does all of that
sorting and that nice stuff
that we saw, with
auto-complete and so forth,
just by creating, first of
all, the div for your panel.
Create a new storeLocator.Panel,
pass it
into View, good to go.
So I'm not going to go to too
much more detail here.
The point being, as great
examples in that library, it's
really easy to get started.
NABIL NAGHDY: Yeah, so the first
thing you want to do
when you're importing your data
is kind of change the way
it looks to customize it.
And the easiest way to do that
is to use custom icons.
So in this instance, we've
simply replaced the red pin
and put in a funky blue house.
Now, this is a fundamental
thing that
everyone should be doing.
The least you can kind of change
is the red pin, to make
it relevant to whatever
you're doing.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, absolutely.
In this case, house kind
of makes sense.
But it could be
different-colored houses,
dynamically, if it had a
fireplace or some other
attributes, or different sizes
for the price, et cetera.
So always do the custom icons.
I just want to briefly
go over--
I mean, this is not a new
concept to most of you.
There is one new thing in here
though, so briefly go over how
you customize your icons.
The easiest way, just what we
did here is basically, in your
marker options, you
have an icon.
And you can pass it in
a number of things.
The first and easiest
is just URL, so
in this case, house.png.
That's my image.
And that's all I have to do.
I'm done.
We get a little more complicated
by creating a
marker image and passing
a bunch of different
variables, resize it.
Of course, when you have a
shadow, it's another marker
image, and so forth.
So that's a great way to go.
That's been around a while.
And then, just out of curiosity,
how many of you
were in the session previously,
on visualization?
Yeah.
So we introduced a really cool
new feature, symbols.
So this is a really great way
we can use some pre-defined
symbols, such as a circle.
You see here.
Our arrows, we have a variety
of pre-defined symbols.
Or pass in your own arbitrary
SVG path,
which is really amazing.
So if I was an artist, I
could've drawn a house SVG
path and then used those and
animated them and done some
really great stuff
with the symbols.
So any of these three are kind
of valid ways to create icons.
And then, you just go ahead.
And in the case of the Store
Locator, if I want to
customize my icon, I would
create a createMarker method
on my View and then pass
in your kind of
classic marker options.
This is the location.
It would be the store
location.
Icon, whatever icon I chose.
In this case, my house.png.
And you're good to go.
So definitely, take the
extra three minutes.
Find yourself a free icon.
Find someone to make you one.
A red pin is great, this
beautiful red pin.
But for your map, it's going to
be better to have your own.
NABIL NAGHDY: So as was spoken
earlier in the keynote, a
really powerful way to give
context to your map is to add
satellite imagery.
So at Google, we've got over
20 petabytes of imagery.
Satellite imagery is covered
for 75% of the world's
population.
And we add, every two weeks,
the same amount of imagery
that we did in all of 2006.
So there's a lot of imagery
constantly being updated.
As you can see in this example,
we have 45 degree
imagery, as well, or
oblique imagery.
And you can set which direction
you want to see the
image from.
You also have the ability to--
we can see in Terrain Mode.
So Terrain Mode is really
convenient or really powerful
for, in this instance, for real
estate sites, but also
for fitness and health sites.
To say, if you're riding your
bike from here to Mountain
View or across the bay, what is
the elevation, and what are
the mountains nearby, if you
were to go for run or a cycle
or whatever.
So it's really powerful data
that is really easy to enable.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
So definitely don't just go
with the default load map.
Maybe that makes the
most sense for you.
You're going to, hopefully,
style it, which we'll talk
about in a little bit.
But go ahead and think, does it
make more sense to have the
satellite imagery?
It's very easy to change.
You set the MapTypeId to the
appropriate base data there,
whether it's a hybrid, such
as satellite, with
the labels on top.
The terrain, which is a really
nice, kind of clean view of
looking at data.
The roads are less prominent
and so forth.
And then, for the 45-degree
imagery, just a note that, by
default, we kind of sweep you
into that aerial view.
But if you don't want it, you
can do map.setTilt to 0.
And then, even if we do have
that imagery available in a
city, we'll just keep you
in the satellite mode.
And so then, you'll get that
kind of straight-down-there
looking view for more
zoom levels.
On the other hand, if you do
want that, then definitely
think about setting the heading,
map.setHeading, to
any of the cardinal views, 90
degrees east, 180 south, and
so forth, so that you can give
your users the appropriate
angle, programmatically, or
automatically, depending on
your use case.
So yeah, pretty easy to take
advantage of those different
base layers.
And then we have more layers.
So we have some layers
we threw on top.
I'm just going to take some of
these houses out of the way.
A few different layers that we
have data for, so the first--
we restyled a map with
our cycling data.
We have this for United States
and a bunch of Canada.
This is really useful.
I'll skip this one
for right now.
We also have a Traffic layer.
This comes in Live Traffic,
which is from a variety of
sources, including
local roads.
It's not just freeway data.
So that's really useful.
We have a relatively
new Weather layer.
So this is kind of neat.
You can see the temperature.
I think it's updated every
hour, I believe.
And then, the Panoramio layer,
it's been around a while.
But it is really cool.
And I've seen a few sites
take advantage
of adding the context.
Here in Seattle, I can see all
the bridges, lots of cool
bridges in Seattle.
It's really nice to be able
to get this data on.
Just a couple of notes on the
Panoramio layer and the
Weather layer--
when you load your Maps
JavaScript library, you have
to add those libraries
specifically,
Panoramio and Weather.
And you also have, in the
Weather layer, a Associated
Cloud layer, here.
So those are updated
every hour.
It's pretty cool.
And you can kind of get the
live weather on there.
So this is how you
do it, very easy.
Again, you instantiate a new,
for example, bicycling layer,
set it to the map, or
set to null, if you
want it to go away.
And then, the one difference, in
the Panoramio Layer, is you
can optionally provide a tag
when you instantiate it.
Or set tag, for example,
in this case, bridges.
And it'll filter the pictures
just to ones that have that
tag, so a bunch of data that
we also kind of provide for
extra context on top.
There's also layers that you can
provide yourself, such as
the KML layer.
That might be your own data,
or some KML you found
somewhere, or a fusion tables
layer, again, your data.
But we're just talking about
data that we provide here, on
top of the map.
NABIL NAGHDY: So now, we'll get
to custom styles, which is
a surprisingly important and
quite less-frequently-used
feature of the Google
Maps API.
So just a quick show of hands,
how many people have heard
about being able to custom
style your map?
OK.
So that's--
And how many people actually
custom style their map?
So that's about 20% to 30%.
So it's quite good.
I think we have a
pretty advanced
group in here, as well.
So styling your map, I think, is
a surprisingly easy feature
that should be utilized
by everyone.
So the default colors of Google
Maps, that it currently
has, is mainly used for
maps.google.com.
And you have the ability to kind
of change it to what fits
your brand.
So if you have really important
data that you're
layering on top, you can kind of
make the background look a
little more subtle.
If there are some features that
you're highlighting, for
example, if you're a trailing
site, you can highlight the
national parks in the map.
So they stand out.
So these are all types of
features that you can utilize
in order to differentiate your
map from your competitors.
So in all these examples, it's
rotating between the--
each one of these examples took
us about five minutes to
create with the Styling Wizard,
which was launched
last year at I/O. If you simply
just Google Google Maps
Styling Wizard, you can
come up with it.
And basically, every minor,
granular feature of the map,
you can change, the color,
the hue, the
saturation, the gamma.
And you can turn things
on and off.
It's really, really powerful.
And as was explained earlier, it
doesn't impact the speed at
which your tiles are rendered.
So every single tile you see is
custom delivered to you, in
your style, in less than
10 milliseconds.
JOSH LIVNI: Yes.
That's a really phenomenal
feature.
And there's just a ton
of granularity on
what you can style.
I'm not going to go into too
much, just point out that
really simple code style,
kind of classic case.
You have some data you'd like
to put on top of the map.
It's pretty standard.
Our map, maps.google.com, is
designed for people who want
directions, all these
other things.
You may not need all
of that stuff
jumping out at your users.
Set the saturation way back.
So you need a really
simple style.
Take everything, kind of make
it a little bit more gray
scale, done.
So strongly recommend--
first of all, like Nabil
mentioned, always style your
map, kind of match your
brand of your website.
It's really worth the extra
half hour in the Styling
Wizard to get something
that fits your needs.
Maybe hire a designer.
It's pretty easy to use.
And they can do really
cool cartography.
And on that note,
definitely check
out the session tomorrow.
It's, I believe, at 4 o'clock,
a master class in styling.
Really exciting stuff
going on in styling.
I strongly recommend you check
out some of the styling
functionality that the
Maps can offer.
NABIL NAGHDY: All right.
So let's get into the meat of
some of the features that
we're going to use.
So in this case, this is going
back to the Store Locator.
So directions is another one
of the features that you do
get for free as part of
the Store Locator.
If I were to click on one of
the houses, I can have the
option of doing Straight View,
which is quite-- everyone
knows about the Straight View.
You can also zoom in on that
specific location.
Then there's directions.
So I click Directions.
And then I want to travel from
the Google Kirkland office.
Awesome.
And as you can see, for those
that are keen-eyed, this isn't
regular driving directions
or cycling.
This is actually transit
directions, which launched
this afternoon.
So you can see that it's
telling me to walk four
minutes and then jump on
a bus by Sound Transit.
So I'm assuming it's a pretty
popular Seattle-based--
JOSH LIVNI: People love them.
NABIL NAGHDY: People
love Sound Transit.
And so it basically tells us
every route, every step of the
way, what requires walking,
what requires
bus, requires subway.
There's a lot of different
variables you get back from
it, which I think Josh will
talk about in a second.
But in this case, we've
used Transit.
Obviously, you can use Cycling,
Walking, or Driving.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, this is
a pretty useful feature.
First of all, going back to the
Store Locator, it's great.
You get directions for free.
And you could have a little
dropdown choosing between
which mode of transport
you like.
And yeah, Transit, I'm
pretty excited about.
It's been the number
one feature
request for quite awhile.
And so I'm just going to show
you how easy it is to change
it, kind of one line of change
from your regular driving
directions.
We make a request, got a start
and end point, bunch of other
options, way points, and so
forth, don't necessarily apply
to Transit.
So we'll go a little bit more
about what you can with
Transit now.
But for the short term, just
note, all you do is set your
travel mode to Transit.
And you're done.
And then you get back some
response that we'll look at in
a little bit.
And in this case, I'm setting
the Directions Display.
So it renders all of that stuff
automatically for me.
But of course, you also get
back a JSON result, with a
bunch of data.
Here's an example of what you
get back from Web Service.
So we also launched transit
on the Web Service today.
So you can use that through
the HTTP API.
And this is just a small
snippet of the code
that you get back.
But just pointing out some
of the things you get.
For example, you get, obviously,
when your bus, or
funicular, or ferry is going to
arrive, and so forth, a lot
of stuff there.
NABIL NAGHDY: There's,
like, 20 different
types of transit vehicles.
JOSH LIVNI: Yep.
So you get that.
You get the number of stops.
NABIL NAGHDY: There's also
horse and carriages.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
Actually, they probably
have them here.
So for example, this is from
Moscone Center to Golden Gate
Park, 32 stops.
That's not a quick bus.
But you eventually get there.
It gives you the time that the
bus is going to arrive, in a
few different formats, like a
nice, easy display format
that's always in the local
time of the user.
That's kind of nice.
And you get the head sign,
like which direction it's
traveling, Ocean Beach.
You get headway, which is if
you miss it, when we expect
the next one will come, like
how many minutes, bunch of
other really useful
information.
So that's great.
And then, you can construct
your own
estimates on the transit.
And yeah, it works
really well.
NABIL NAGHDY: It's
really powerful.
And, guys, try it out.
Mock up some mashups, just see
what you can do with it and
provide feedback.
So we're really, really excited
to have launched it
this afternoon.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, we're excited
to see the transit
stuff out there.
A quick note on the transit,
it launched to all the
countries that we have transit
for, in maps.google.com.
That's what, over how
many countries?
NABIL NAGHDY: Over 475 different
locales, so not
countries, specifically.
JOSH LIVNI: Minus Japan,
not in Japan.
But everywhere else, so really,
really good coverage
for transit.
NABIL NAGHDY: Yeah,
almost global.
So let's move on to some
of the other features.
So another show of hands, who is
familiar with the Distance
Matrix or the concept
of Distance Matrix?
OK, who's used the Distance
Matrix API Web Service?
Brilliant.
For those at home, there's,
like, one hand up.
JOSH LIVNI: He works
at Google.
NABIL NAGHDY: Yeah.
So Distance Matrix is an
incredibly powerful tool.
There's a quick demo, just to
show exactly how it works and
what the purpose is.
So in this example, we've all
the parks that are in San
Francisco, Golden Gate Park,
San Bruno Mountain
State Park, et cetera.
So I am in Moscone Center.
I have a friend that
lives in Glen Park.
And so what this gives me is the
distance between all the
destinations and the origin, as
well as the time it'll take
for the method of transport
that I've selected.
So in this case, we can
determine what the distance
is, or amount of time it takes
to drive from Moscone Center
and Glen Park to any
of these parks.
So we could also figure
out how long it'll
take to cycle there.
So if we were to cycle, looking
at this I'd say, I'm
in Moscone, my friend
is in Glen Park.
Let's meet at Dolores Park
because it's clearly,
perfectly in the middle, 20
minutes and 15 minutes to
cycle there.
So you can go in the Distance
Matrix either JavaScript
service, or in the Web
Service itself.
You can have up to 100 cells.
So that's like a 10
by 10 matrix.
And it's essentially--
in this case, rather than doing
10 separate Directions
requests, you do one request.
And you get all the
results back.
And you display it.
So how does this example relate
to Store Locator or
housing site, in our case?
The icons have gone red.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, I filtered out
all the ones that didn't
have a fireplace.
NABIL NAGHDY: OK, so the
red ones mean fire?
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, pretty good.
NABIL NAGHDY: And
it's night time.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
NABIL NAGHDY: OK, cool.
JOSH LIVNI: Fireplaces
are a hazard.
NABIL NAGHDY: So let's
say we are,
again, in Google Kirkland.
JOSH LIVNI: Yes.
NABIL NAGHDY: So I like
to drive to work.
So let's say, driving.
As you can see, we haven't
reordered the results.
But what you can tell is, that
on the left-hand panel, you
can see the distance between the
Google Kirkland office and
that specific house,
as well as the time
it'll take to drive.
I actually like to
cycle to work.
So can I see the cycling
directions?
Awesome.
So anything under an
hour, there's one
that's 40 minutes there.
So that would be in my subset
of houses I'd look at.
JOSH LIVNI: So what's nice here
is that we can start to
annotate the different types
of places your users might
want to go really, really
quickly, annotate lots of them
at a time, and then start
ranking those things.
Maybe I said my criteria for
houses is things I can bike to
in half an hour.
I don't have to make a separate
request to each one,
so a lot of use cases here
for the Distance Matrix.
NABIL NAGHDY: Yeah,
really powerful.
JOSH LIVNI: Definitely
check it out.
All right.
Let's see here.
Yes.
Code for Distance Matrix is
very similar to a Driving
Directions request, except
instead of having an origin
and a destination, they
can be lists.
So in the case of the house
example, I still only have one
origin, where I work, for
example, and then a list of
houses, house one, house two,
house three, and so forth.
I pass that off.
I can pass similar options in
the request, including extra
options, like avoiding tolls,
and other such things you can
do with directions.
And then in a single response,
I get all of those back.
So in this particular case, I
get back a response with a
result of one row, because
I only had one origin.
And then each of those would
have the time it would take.
You don't get back all the
information, like you would
with directions, such as
the steps, and the
routes, and so forth.
You get back just the travel
time and travel distance, but
a really great way to start
annotating your data from
place to place, when you
have multiple places.
Maybe you want to have some
friends meet in the middle,
and so forth.
All right, Distance Matrix,
hope you check it out.
NABIL NAGHDY: So the next thing
is Optimized Directions.
So let's say it's a
Saturday morning.
And there's a handful
of houses that
I've selected to see.
So let's pick, say, the top five
or top six houses that we
want to see.
Brilliant.
And you can see the bottom
of the left-hand panel.
It totals up the number
of minutes it
takes for me to travel.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
So in this case, instead of
automatically rendering all
the directions, I just
grab the JSON back.
I'm parsing it for each
leg along the way.
And then I sum them up at
the top, so three hours.
NABIL NAGHDY: So in this case,
we've got a three hour and 10
minute drive, if I were to go in
the order of places where I
was clicked.
So that's a pretty
solid drive.
And it's a big waste of
a Saturday morning.
JOSH LIVNI: That sounded
right, yeah.
NABIL NAGHDY: So what
if I were to click
the Optimize button?
As you can see, the time now is
two hours and 14 minutes.
So we've just saved an hour,
because it reorders all the
different pins that I've
selected, all the different
locations I've selected, and
determines what the fastest
route is, essentially going in
a circle, between all the
different points.
So rather than an order that
I've selected them, it
reorders them to give you the
fastest possible route.
The other thing is, I
think this route is
going through a bridge.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, the 520
here, newly tolled.
NABIL NAGHDY: So I don't
want to pay tolls.
So it adds an extra--
I think that was 15 minutes.
It's a pretty big detour.
But I avoid the tolls, which
in this case, I would take.
So that's another feature which
is also baked in, is to
avoid tolls.
And the code for this
is also really,
really easy to implement.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, so the
Optimized Directions just have
a lot of different
use cases, maybe
running a bunch of errands.
Maybe people are going to a
vacation site and they want to
see a bunch of different
things.
Take advantage of the fact that
we've kind of solved this
tricky, traveling-salesman
problem for you.
So it's very, very useful.
Our Optimized Direction code
should start looking pretty
similar here, with our
first request.
Also, you can use this in the
Web Service, of course.
The two features I added
here were just
options on my request.
OptimizeWaypoints, true,
default is false.
And similarly with avoidTolls,
set those to true, and you
could take advantage there.
So this is really
useful features.
You're making any type of
directions request.
You've got some way points,
along the way.
Think about whether it's going
to be best for users to give
them this option or not.
And oftentimes, it will.
NABIL NAGHDY: All right.
So now we have another API,
which is called the Google
Places API.
It's also a service within the
JavaScript, which we're using
in this case.
And what that allows us to do,
in this housing site that
we've created, is determine
what are specific places
around the points of the houses
that I'm interested in.
So what we can do is we can
click on a certain house.
And in this case, we have
schools enabled.
And it will tell me all the
schools that are surrounding
this house.
And it does it for each one.
I don't like water, so I
wouldn't live on an island.
Yeah, OK.
So essentially, you
guys get the idea.
So are there any
other options?
As was mentioned in the keynote,
there's around 100
different categories you
can choose from.
In this case, we've
selected a vet.
If you have an ill pet, and you
really want to live close
to a vet, you can
do that as well.
JOSH LIVNI: I'm curious,
where are the vets?
NABIL NAGHDY: The options
are innumerable.
JOSH LIVNI: Quite a lot.
Oh, wow.
NABIL NAGHDY: OK.
So let's say, if I was to look
for schools around a certain
house, there's also another
really cool feature, where I
can filter what Places category
I've selected.
So I really like the
Montessori system.
So for my kids, I'd want to put
in a Montessori school,
for them to go to.
So I select Montessori.
And now, when I click a house, I
actually get the location of
all the Montessori
schools near the
house that I've selected.
JOSH LIVNI: I was going
to mention.
It's important to mention what
we're doing here in the
background is using the
keyword feature
on the Places request.
And that filters not just on
description and name, but also
on the reviews and some
other information that
we have on the place.
So if someone says, this school
is absolutely not a
Montessori school in one
of the comments,
it'll still show up.
It's a great way to filter
down quickly.
Just keep in mind what
the keyword does.
And it's still, as you can see,
really, really useful, if
you're looking for something
specific, Italian restaurant
versus restaurants,
and so forth.
NABIL NAGHDY: So in this case,
it looks like West Seattle has
got two Montessori schools
close to each other.
So let's zoom in and have a look
and see what the houses
look like there.
JOSH LIVNI: All right.
I think we can go to the
next demo for this one.
NABIL NAGHDY: All righty.
So we've got West Seattle,
Montessori schools.
JOSH LIVNI: There they are.
NABIL NAGHDY: Ah, Montessori.
JOSH LIVNI: Picky with
your schools.
NABIL NAGHDY: Yeah,
very picky.
In this demo, if we click on
the school, and we have
selected the house, it gives
us the walking directions
between the two points.
Now, that red kind of squiggly
line that's going above the
directions is actually the
elevation between the house
I've selected and the
school itself.
So if I want to walk to the
school and walk my kids to
school, then this would be a
really awesome way for me to
instantaneously see.
OK, this is a bit of
an uphill walk.
So I'd go downhill, initially.
And then I'd be walking
uphill to the school.
So I'd probably not
want to do that.
I'd probably want
to go somewhere
where it's a flat walk.
This, obviously, is also the
case if you're trying to pick
a neighborhood and if you live
on top of a hill and all the
restaurants you want to go
to are down the hill.
It's important information.
So this is also incredibly
powerful for elevation,
especially for health
and fitness sites.
If you want to determine the
directions between two points,
you can easily, now with
visualization, add this layer
on top, really powerful.
JOSH LIVNI: Yes.
This is pretty cool stuff, using
the new symbols again,
which we'll get into
in a second here.
But the point here that we have
is, with places, don't
just think of it as occasionally
your user might
need to see what's
around them.
Or I'm building a place's
business.
But you can use it in all kinds
of places, just to get a
quick look at local density.
I'd love it, when I'm looking
at the different housing
sites, just to get an idea of
the density of things that are
around me that I care about.
I care about, perhaps, schools
because I have kids, parks,
coffee shop, bar, maybe
not much else.
And so I just want to know
where are those things
relative to the houses
I'm looking at.
It applies to many different
verticals, again.
So use it in all your
applications, if you want to
give the end-user sort of a
portal into all of the stuff
that we have around
a given location.
Also, think about using
the keyword filtering.
Think about, in this case, we
were sorting by distance,
which is a relatively
new feature.
And so usually, we sort by
what's called prominence,
which gets the best results.
I was just curious of the
closest results, even if
they're not necessarily
the best.
So maybe, if I looked for coffee
shops, we think the
best results are a little
more spread out.
I just want the closest one.
I want to know if I'm
in a block or two.
So think about how you're going
to rank the response.
And think about how to sort of
mix and match the services.
That's the main point here.
You don't have to just think,
OK, I'm a real estate site, so
put some pins in a map
with some prices.
Think about, oh, people
are probably
going to walk to places.
If they walk to somewhere, we
should give directions and let
them know, oh, it's
a 10-minute walk
or a 15-minute walk.
Or it's going to be uphill,
et cetera, et cetera.
So think of all the different
services you can combine when
you're using Places.
And then also, don't miss the
session right after this--
"Building a Business with the
Places API." So they have a
lot of good stuff to
talk about Places
in much more detail.
Briefly mentioned the
elevation here.
So you notice that very
cool symbology.
The symbols were mentioned
in the previous talk.
So I'm not going to talk
about how we did
the symbols too much.
But check out the video
on YouTube afterwards
if you missed it.
It's a very cool talk on Spatial
Data Visualization.
And then the elevation, however,
I'll just mention, is
again kind of a similar
pattern here.
We make a request to an
Elevation Service.
In this case, we're going to
pass in a path that we want
elevation for and a
number of samples.
In this case, I want 500
samples along the path.
It'll evenly interpolate those
samples along the way.
I could also, if I was so
inclined, just ask for a
single location, get the
elevation back for there.
So in this case, I've already
done a Directions request to
get some walking directions.
So I've got an overview path
from the route that was
returned to me from
the directions.
I pass that into
the Elevation.
Elevation will return an array
of Elevation responses, which
include the height, the
accuracy of the
elevation, and so forth.
So Elevation API, very useful.
NABIL NAGHDY: Powerful.
JOSH LIVNI: Yep, OK.
NABIL NAGHDY: All right.
So our final demo for this
afternoon is a really powerful
way in which, for this case
and others, you can really
utilize the power of
Google's mapping
services or Geo services.
In this case, we've selected
the different houses that
we're interested in.
And let's say, you
get a URL from
your real estate provider.
And it looks something
like this.
So basically, these are
all the different
houses we've selected.
But what we're doing is, we've
passed it into the Google
Earth API, Google Earth
API plug-in.
And we're able to do a flyover,
or virtual tour, of
all the different houses
that we've selected.
There's a lot of things that
are variable, the speed at
which you fly.
In this case, you're rotating.
It's a really immersive
experience.
And it doesn't just apply
to real estate sites.
For example, there was one
recently for the Tour de
France, which is starting next
week, where it basically flies
over the entire route.
It's a really awesome way
to visualize your data.
And I think it's quite
underutilized.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
So definitely check
out the Earth API.
If you already have an existing
Maps V3 website, then
it's really easy to add an
Earth button that just
magically has most of your
markers, polygons, other
overlays, and so forth,
appear for the user.
NABIL NAGHDY: You
can fly through.
JOSH LIVNI: And then, you can
add these effects by accessing
that Google Earth itself.
But if you want to use that
library, you can go to the
Maps V3 Utility Libraries.
And there's an open source
library called Earth.
And that will basically, in a
couple of lines of code, let
you add the Earth button, so
that you don't have to change
anything in your existing
content.
But users who click on Earth--
or you can programmatically
enable it-- can fly around
Earth, seeing most of the
stuff that you've already
put on the map.
All right.
NABIL NAGHDY: All right.
We seem to have a--
JOSH LIVNI: Different window.
NABIL NAGHDY: We seem to have
wrapped up a little bit early.
So I guess, are there
any questions?
Or I mean, what we wanted to
show in this session was how
important it is to give
your maps an extra
bit of oomph, really.
I guess it's really
easy to implement
some of these features.
Some of them require
a bit of work.
But in a weekend, for example,
you can turn a regular red pin
on a map-type of website into a
really immersive interactive
experience for your users.
And you'd really stand out in
your specific vertical.
So hopefully, some of these
examples have been
useful to you guys.
Thank you.
JOSH LIVNI: All right.
Thanks a lot.
And if you have questions,
just line up
behind the mics there.
And I'm very curious to hear
what you have to say.
AUDIENCE: The loading of the
libraries, now you have to
load them with the API.
Would it be possible in the
future to load them after the
API has been loaded?
JOSH LIVNI: Are you talking
about the Earth API?
AUDIENCE: The Maps API, the
libraries, like Places and--
JOSH LIVNI: Oh, sorry.
So you're saying, if you want to
use Places, you have to add
the Libraries equals Places,
or Panoramio, and so forth.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, so we do that
by design, in order to
send you the minimal amount of
JavaScript to get the fastest
loading times.
If you're in a mobile device,
we don't want to
send over an extra--
NABIL NAGHDY: All
the libraries.
JOSH LIVNI: --5K of data
that you don't need.
And so some sites need
some things.
Some sites need some
other things.
If you don't need the Weather
and Cloud layer, we don't want
to send those bits over
to your users.
AUDIENCE: Could it be enabled
so you could load them
dynamically by, instead of
typing, Google.load--
JOSH LIVNI: Oh, I think I
see what you're saying.
So you've already instantiated
your Map instance.
And you want add in the--
that's a really
good feature request.
Please use the Issue Tracker.
I don't know if you were
in the earlier session.
We should point this out again,
that the Issue Tracker,
we really take it seriously.
So if you have a good feature
request like that, search for
the Maps API Issue Tracker,
add it in.
The more people who star it,
such as Transit, then the
harder we work to get
it out to you guys.
So I see your question now.
It was a really good one.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering if there's any
plans or info on if the
traffic data will be available
through the API?
I know there's a
Traffic layer.
But if you could just get access
to the raw traffic
data, without the Map layer.
NABIL NAGHDY: Right now, that's
probably not in the
cards, to just give just the
amount of traffic of--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, if you could
give it a certain geo area and
get the traffic for--
NABIL NAGHDY: Most
probably, not.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: So you talk about
styling for Maps.
Can you do this on
the Android Maps?
NABIL NAGHDY: Good question.
Right now, you can do it-- if
you're obviously in the
browser, the JavaScript itself
would be restyled.
But in App, using WebView
or iOS using WebKit, no.
AUDIENCE: OK.
All right, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hello, this is
Ho Ming from Hong Kong.
Two quick questions.
First, you showed about the
Elevation API and then got
some red lines depicting
the elevation.
Can I change the color or change
the style of such path?
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
I kind of skipped over that
part because there was a
session earlier on the Spatial
Data Visualization.
I think all these sessions are
going to be live, at the end
of the day, on YouTube, that
you can check out.
And Enoch there went into some
really great detail on exactly
how he created the symbols along
that polyline and all of
the symbology options
that you can apply
to markers and polylines.
So the short answer is,
yes, absolutely.
You can change those
dynamically, set the color
stroke, all of these
different things, a
super flexible library.
I don't want to show the
code and kind of
repeat a previous session.
But it's live.
And I think the documentation,
if you want
to see the new symbols.
Or for that particular example,
check out the YouTube
video of the Spatial--
AUDIENCE: And another quick
question is on the Transit
information, because I have
recently entered San Francisco
and found the transit
information really useful.
But for Hong Kong, the
transit information
seems not too accurate.
Is there any way that we, as a
user of the Google Maps and
[? key ?] user, can help improve
some data or the tour
information?
NABIL NAGHDY: Report a Problem,
those are actually
quite frequently used.
And they're really
valuable to us.
So if you see something
wrong--
for example, if you go to
maps.google.com, and you
search for transit directions
in Hong Kong, if you see
something is incorrect, if you
click Report a Problem and
say, this station is in the
wrong place, or these are the
wrong times, then that will then
go to a team which will
actually look to
implement that.
And if it's either, A, something
wrong with the way
we're using the data, or, B,
faulty data, we'll find the
source of the problem, and
then try and fix it.
And then, whatever is on
maps.google.com is
mirrored in the API.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
NABIL NAGHDY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
It's for the Distance Matrix.
You said there was different
methods of transit.
Can you go across continents?
Like, I'd say, by boat,
airplane, or something, with
the Distance Matrix?
JOSH LIVNI: No.
So you can use driving, walking,
and if you're in the
United States or Canada,
bicycling.
And those are the only modes
of transit available.
And you cannot drive, walk, or
bicycle across the ocean.
NABIL NAGHDY: If you were, for
example, in Spain, and you
were to, say, get Distance
Matrix from Spain to Russia,
wherever we can normally
return a directions
request, then yes.
But across continents, we
don't do cross vehicle.
JOSH LIVNI: But I think your
question was maybe, like,
airline data.
Could that get fit in?
AUDIENCE: Airline or
boat data or--
JOSH LIVNI: That is a really
interesting feature request.
But no.
Right now, it's just
limited to the same
three travel modes.
NABIL NAGHDY: And it's also
adding things like planes and
things like that to Directions
Request itself, which
currently isn't available.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The Distance Matrix
was very cool.
Do you have anything that would
help people implement a
walk score, which is--
JOSH LIVNI: Yes.
So the Places API, combined with
the Distance Matrix, you
might use something--
I think what you're asking
is getting to the point I
mentioned earlier of approximate
density of things
that are around you,
in a given area.
But of course, if you're on one
side of the river and all
the density is on the other side
of the river, and there's
no bridges nearby, that's
not really useful.
So could you figure out what are
the closest places, as the
crow flies, as we say in the
States, and then, also use the
Distance Matrix to assign
the travel time,
by different modes?
So if you're just a bicycling
person, you might get
different weightings for
different places.
And absolutely, yeah, it's
a great use for that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, quick question
about the usage of Google Maps
and the API on Android.
So you basically said that all
of these things are available
on Android, using the standard
browser or via Chrome.
But I found it, from a user
experience, to be kind to
lacking, as opposed to the
desktop experience.
Now, Android has this MapView
native component.
But that obviously doesn't work
with the Google Maps API.
So what is the kind
of approach?
Given the fact that more and
more people are starting to
use smartphones, tablets, what
is the role of Google Maps in
that respect?
NABIL NAGHDY: That's a
very good question.
Right now, we are kind of
promoting the use of--
I guess, for native
applications, you
would access WebView.
Through the web, you'd access
the JavaScript.
I'd say--
that's a very good question.
JOSH LIVNI: It would really
just depend a lot on your
application, depending on the
amount of data you're loading,
if it's super important
that you have
an immediate load-time.
We realize there's an
additional lag.
Obviously, you're going to be
loading the JavaScript library
if you go through
the Maps API.
On the other hand, you get
a bunch of new features.
So the focus today was on the
new features of the Maps API.
We don't have anything new to
announce, right now, about the
other options that you
might have natively.
So it's kind of just a tough
call for you, that makes the
best sense for your
application.
AUDIENCE: Right, OK.
Thanks.
NABIL NAGHDY: Good answer.
AUDIENCE: Can you make some
comment about the library.
You mentioned a Store Location
library versus a Fusion Table
and versus the Vector API, which
you are about to release
very soon, later this year.
The way you use it-- and I know
Fusion Table is mainly
for small business.
What about the library
you mentioned?
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, so the Store
Locator library-- the point I
was trying to make when I was
loading up the houses there
with the Static Data Feed--
and it could also potentially
be a dynamic
feed, such as a database.
It's that it could be
arbitrary database.
The Store Locator library is
completely agnostic, regarding
where you're loading
your data from.
It doesn't care at all.
And we make it pretty easy
to be very pluggable with
different data sources.
A kind of a separate question
from the Store Locator library
is, what's the best spatial
database of choice.
If you're an enterprise
customer, looking for certain
sort of features, more consumer,
looking for a
different set of features, you
run your own MySQL database
in-house and so forth.
It's kind of a separate question
of what best fits
your needs.
But this particular example was
just a lot of people have
a spreadsheet for a couple
of hundred stores.
Or they might have a MySQL
instance already up and
running, that they're doing
all their stuff in with a
million places.
And we don't care at all with
the Store Locator library.
Just plug it right in.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
kind of capacity?
What's the size of data it
can host, the library?
JOSH LIVNI: Oh, yeah.
So the static data feed, you're
basically loading all
the data at once.
So by the time you're loading
a few thousand things, you
have kind of bandwidth issues,
as a bunch of data you have to
load and then parsing time.
And so, if it's a static data
feed, I would say, less than a
couple thousand, depending
on the browser,
maybe 1,000 or less.
Otherwise, go for a dynamic data
feed, something that you
can request a smaller
subset at a time.
It very much varies, if you're
going to be on the desktop or
mobile, bandwidth
and so forth.
But general rule of thumb, I
like to think, although you
can certainly do more, tens of
thousands of markers sent
over, why send over more than
1,000 at a time if someone is
only going to look at 10?
It doesn't make sense.
AUDIENCE: So pretty
much it's the same
range of Fusion Table?
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
With Dart coming out, how
seamless do you see the
transition being between Dart
and JavaScript, as far as
these APIs go?
JOSH LIVNI: So as far as these
APIs go, we don't have any
Dart-specific plans.
As far as the really good
general question of JavaScript
and Dart, there's a whole series
of Dart sessions, where
they're focusing just on that.
And they're going to talk a lot
about best practices and
exactly that kind of question.
So I'd say, that is probably
a better place to go.
I'm not a Dart expert.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk a little
bit about interactions
between different layers
on the map?
NABIL NAGHDY: Interactions
of different layers.
JOSH LIVNI: Such as?
AUDIENCE: Such as, if there is
a store and a bunch of people
are checking in at another
store, like within five miles
from that, you could do
something about that.
JOSH LIVNI: So there's
a few answers.
Yes, if you're using the Places
API, there's a number
of things you can do, including
something that we
call a Check-in.
It's a little bit of
a confusing name.
And it kind of, basically,
bumps the ranking.
So you have people on your
app checking in.
Like, you have a
bunch of users.
They're doing some
types of events.
And there's a bunch of places
being returned.
And they're checking in,
through your app.
You can create a posted
Check-in, to the Places API,
to that place.
And future users of your app
will see that place's
prominence ranked higher.
So if everyone is hitting up one
coffee shop through your
app, next person who searches
will see that one.
I don't know if that was your
question exactly, but that
would be kind of one
approach to that.
AUDIENCE: Something a little bit
more abstract, like just
if maybe a bunch of things are
happening at a certain
location and there also happens
to be something else
happening on a certain location,
but it's on a
different layer.
How do you have those
two interact?
NABIL NAGHDY: As in, if you had
something on the Traffic
layer, if you had a bunch of--
like a grid, and then you had
something on the
Bicycle layer.
For example, can you combine
[INAUDIBLE]?
JOSH LIVNI: Why don't
we talk after?
I'm not 100% sure I
got your question.
But we might.
And we can talk about it after,
just in case there's
any other last-minute
questions here.
We're almost out of time.
NABIL NAGHDY: We'll also be at
the office hours, as well.
In the Geo--
down there.
JOSH LIVNI: Any other
last-minute questions?
OK.
Well, I think we'll
wrap it up.
Thanks a lot, guys.
We really appreciate the time.
And yeah, please take
advantage of
some of these services.
They're really simple, add a
lot of value to your maps.